сказали що мене забирають затримують на
30 днів А дитину швидше за все заберуть у
дитбудинок повітря не церковують скрізь
таргани трапляються їсти хочеться Ну
звичайно козу там особливе ставлення
Азов страждає найбільше
вони дуже злі у них менталітет не такий
як у нас у Росії багатьох дівчаток катували
по різному
електрошокерами та всім на світі мене
просто
Віта Вікторія дякує смішні годинник
сили знамену поспілку ватосі нібито
відчуває Чиї ви вже викладу того ще в
Україні
вже все добре
звичайно перші два дні ми ще купили так
не розуміли що ми в Україні що тепер
не треба їсти на швидкості все інше
там як було в полоні тепер уже звичайно
так все добре А я до ваших Здоров'я
нормально Тут надають допомогу нас
забезпечує
у салоні побували скрізь і всюди
відновити
а ми йому вірних виливалися за вас і за
вашу доньку Алісу може раз повести
зайти в саму обставу на вас розлучив з
Як тебе звати Аліса Що ти хочеш
сказати
а де ти зараз знаходишся
тори для цивільних мене спробували
вивести з цивільними вона повезли в
безіменне там я звичайно фільтрація не
пройшла так звісно
я військова вони відразу це дізналися сказали
що мене забирають затримують на 30 днів
А дитину швидше за все заберуть до дитбудинку
але дозволив Червоний Хрест дозволив
зателефонувати мамі мама сказала щоб я
привезла якось якимось
способом дитини
до Запоріжжя ця колона йшла і тому
познайомилася фільтрацією на
фільтраційний пункт з дівчинкою
там ми жили у наметовому містечку тому
що з дитиною а так би я жила в камері
і страшно стало колись з дитиною нас
почали розлучати нас сказали вийти з
автобуса
у нас доглянули мангуші та сказали
садити на заднє сидіння говорю Ні
чому говорю тому що нехай дитина і
далі Ну якщо я вже потрапляю до Стрічки
Навіщо мені поряд дитина я ж розумію
що зі мною не буде її просто
кудись заберуть, а потім де шукати кінці
але цього невідомо
і відповідно Я дуже довго просила
вони порадилися і дозволили мені
все-таки відправити дитину до запиту я
звичайно їхала вже по етапу Я фарбую
донька відро вали на течу що я є
вам і розлучати чайові піддувало
Я сказала що вона їде До дядька що там з
ним все добре буде, а я 40 днів приїду
намагалася
і вас не можна розлучать і якони
звичайно намагалася це пояснити і тому
я жила не в камері А ці два дні я жила
все-таки в наметі з дитиною тому що
сказала що її треба годувати її треба
стежити, щоб вона не розкривалася вночі
зачіску зробити вмити ви будете це
робити Ні говорю Дозвольте мені звичайно
з нею весь цей час перебувати потім уже
торкнеться Я вже звичайно в полон Але і
назустріч звичайно дозволили щоб
помилувала в полоні після того, як мене
затримали на мангуші мене відвезли до
Донецьку УБОЗ 9 травня
там я жила в убопі
до 31 травня 31 Мене перевели до ізолятора
тимчасового утримання і там звичайно
умови жахливі повітря не терплять
скрізь таргани трапляються їсти хочеться
тому тарганів Ти просто прибираєш і
їсти далі
воду перед крана
чай такого взагалі не було.
є собою чай Добре ти можеш
попросити якщо ні це твої проблеми
а потім Мене перевели в Оленівку
1 червня
там умови ще гірші звичайно
маленькі камери десь 3 на 4 метри
нажила 11 людей
потім це двомісна камера потім
перевели у шість місцевий там ми жили 24
людини
відповідно воду нам привозили в
ній навіть мальки траплялися А коли в
серпні початку
блукати вода відповідно це було з
присмаком Тіни а я спав і по рисі по
дві людини на шконці на підлозі
просто стелили і поряд лягали ось
одна людина повертається допустимо на
правий бік і всі повинні повернутися
тому що по-іншому але я б назвала
це як оселедці А чому вас привозив із
Місія на місці він пояснювала, бо
в ізоляторі тимчасового утримання
Якщо не помиляюся 90 днів тримати не
можуть ніхто нічого не пояснює називають
прізвище з речами на вихід нікуди ти
їдеш ніскільки часу, коли нічого ти
не можеш цього дізнатися
перевезли в Оленівку там до 14 жовтня
сиділа в зеленівці, а потім відвезли в
Таганрог теж так заходить прізвище
назвали збираюся з речами на вихід Нас
залишалося вже 4 особи всі дівчатка
Трохи раніше поїхали етапом
ми знали що вони доїжджають Таганрога це
розподільний пункт наскільки ми
знали і далі вони пропадали куди
поділися далі ніхто не знав
Так у мене мама дізналася що я де Олена в
ким Мені дозволили привітати доньку з днем
народження Я дуже довго просила звичайно
не на день народження трохи пізніше але я
змогла зателефонувати і так я мама дізналася, що
я у зеленівці
а потім зв'язали руки зв'язали очі
посадили в Урал і ми кудись їхали.
коли вже приїхали ми нічого не бачили у
нас були заплющені очі
нас зігнули навпіл очі закрили як
вони говорили відкрив очі втратив очі
Вони спрямовують
допустимо ліворуч праворуч сходинка то
є Ти біжиш із заплющеними очима
ходити Там неможливо там тільки бігати
треба а ти не знаєш який бік
сходинка вліво або вправо вгору або
вниз наприклад тому можуть сказати
наліво а там зачинені двері просто і ти
відповідно головою вдаряєшся в
закриті двері якщо
не до кінця зігнувся тебе можуть зігнути
гумовою палицею тому
до хлопчиків ставлення ще гірше А хто був
званий інчі напів нею на різних етапах
весь Кови медики чий цивіль не так вже й
це були і військові та цивільні та
колишні військові люди, які вирішили
залишитися на території Російської
Федерації
там були всі
медики та
всі підрозділи з нами стилю
чебурі у вас у камерах базу віза з собою
гігієни шампуню не було взагалі це
давали на дві пляшечки на всю камеру ми
порошок ми розводили її голову порошком
і миючі якщо для посуду якщо десь
щось
хтось допоможе принесе щось ми або
мило рідке намагалися зробити звичайне
мило ось мило твердо та й прокладок У нас
звичайно вистачало, але тільки в зеленівці
ввести це всього не видавалося тобто
якщо хтось приїхав на фільтрацію там зі
своїми шампунем Ми звичайно просили
викручуватись Канада вивести наприклад
водили в душ раз на тиждень
це не завжди тобто ти можеш місяць
там просидіти без душа це вже за їх
бажанню ми нам привозили технічну
воду ось ми технічною водою мили
я правильно розуміє Вас охороняв і
вимкнені панчохи чебуреки
жінка-охоронців там немає в Таганрозі
була жінка одна і всі інші
чоловіки Я б сказала жінка набагато
жорсткіше там ставиться ніж чоловіки
вони теж кричать
ображають тебе але навіть теленовці були
щоразу ротація щомісяця в них і
були люди які Ну не скажу що з
розумінням але гуляти виводили в душ там
хоча б раз на 45 днів виводили в теплу
воду тому, що деякі могли тебе
поставити просто під крижану А хочеш не
хочеш митися Це вже твоє бажання
Митися треба
у бараках у нас лише близько 100 осіб
було дівчаток тому нас Розмістили
внизу я стала
дівчаткам трохи інший
на цьому звичайно дуже страждають хлопчики
А дівчинка, на що вони можуть зробити
тільки словесно принизити рукаприкладства
Ну до мене принаймні в Оленівці не
було а в інших було
вчені більше тикав росіян Коли вас
водили над досліди в основному хотіли щоб
ми видали свої позиції
питали кого ми знаємо З яких
підрозділів їх Саме підрозділи Ну
звичайно козу там особливе ставлення
Азов страждає найбільше дуже
сподіваємося що їх Ну просто в перших рядах
Тому що їм там не життя над
ними
намагаються повішати якісь справи
які людина не робила наприклад вони
там ну ніби побачили на відео
припустимо щось і вибиваєтеся
людини свідчення і вибиватимуть до
тих пір поки людина справді вже
буде боятися за своє життя щоб ось на
грані життя та смерті він звичайно
погодиться підписати вас
за вашу позицію за те, чого весь кого ви
Звичайно, всі ходили говорили
що
треба було сидіти вдома не треба було йти
служити вони вважають вони чіпляються дуже
сильно за 14 рік
Ось ви в чотирнадцятому році таке таке
наробили тепер ось ну як би це Помста
на відео записували пропагандисті вони
виховали хоче його каже А мені
сказали ти ж розумієш, що це інтерв'ю
відмовитися не можеш говорити Так я
чудово розумію
сказали, що відповісти на які питання на
які я справді не могла
відповісти Просто зупинялися зйомку
говорили відповиш так так і ось так і
знову записували а потім це звернення до
Ірині верещак, щоб мені повернули дитину
Звичайно я розуміла, що мені не потрібен
дитина біля мене мало що її можуть
зробити щоб витягнути з мене
інформацію
на вашу думку Інтерв'ю було Ну я думаю
що коли ці новини вийшли в Росії
то звичайно я красива дієта все як би і
ось я думаю що хотіли показати саме
те що начебто як мені я залишаюся на
території і ось що я хочу продовжувати
жити з дитиною але я не хотіла цього
звичайно я хочу то може він адже
повидатий алея все випробуваю А ще було
для вас мишегою, що наює в полоні
епізод тобою
голову риби тисячу разу в основному це
коли нам закривали годівниці і дуже
сильно знущалися з хлопчиків
завдавали їм дуже сильний біль. А ми це
всі чули морально було ось на нас
був моральний тиск ми це все
слухали
і має бути тиша Тобто ніхто в
цьому в цей момент не повинен
розмовляти всі мають це слухати
у вас був момент такий ви думали що
зламаєтеся
криво було у дружньому вечорі
були такі моменти Звичайно коли
коли треба кидати або наприклад там
вибивали свідчення хочеш не хочеш А ти
розкажеш Тому що ти переживаєш за
своє життя
покаже його бувало Це хто застусовували
фізичну силу над дослідами А вам схоже
було найсильнішому розправам, що тортури
можуть повести
багатьох дівчаток катували по-різному
електрошокерами та всім на світі мене
просто Віля
Які моральний стан інших українців
цуценя полонених Ми всі намагалися
підтримувати один одного знайшли нових
подруг я б сказала що ми не зла мені
ми вірили до останнього, що ось настане
той день коли ми таки повернемося
додому коли нас скасовує І що все буде
добре Ми чекали цього моменту ми
спілкувалися один з одним і підтримували
кому там ставало погано
заспокоювали тому ми стали як одна
велика родина Ви були над складними
вмолах ще вам допомагала трюматосе
надія що у найближчому майбутньому ми
повернемося додому що нас заміняє тому що
нам казали що обміни зриваються
Україна не підтверджує ви нікому не
потрібні за вас всі забули Ми розуміли що
це не так що ми потрібні своїм
родичам потрібні своїй країні звичайно
що нас не брешуть я знала себе що вас
звинувачують за три дні до обміну 14 числа
нам сказали збираєтеся речами на вихід
нас завантажили в Урали кудись везли
коли привезли коли брали ДНК ми
побачили що це місто Таганрог просто
напис був на одному з документів що
місто Таганрог ми зрозуміли що нас
Але що це обмін ми привезли в Таганрог
не знали потім о 5 ранку 17 числа десь
о 5 може півп'ятої
нас підняли сказали з речами на вихід
зв'язали руки
і ми кудись поїхали посадили в автобусі
нас посадили у вантажні само роботи нам
зав'язали очі зав'язали руки ми сиділи
на підлозі у вантажних літаках і кудись
летіли коли прилетіли нас просто
пересадили в Урали, але в уралах у нас уже
супровід був тільки за Уралом то
їсти в машині нікого не було і ми могли
трошки підглянути дорогу але оскільки
ми дівчатка з різних територій України та
дороги різні знаємо зрозуміли що ми їдемо
на територію убік за простіше та на
останнього не вірили однаково щось
обмін що зараз ось кудись звернемо і
поїдемо не в той бік і коли ми
приїхали до Василівки ми знаємо що
минулий обмін був Василівці Ми приїхали
і ось він цей міст, про який все
говорили і
Ну ми до останнього поки не сіли в
Українські комфортабельні автобуси
коли не перейшли цей міст не розв'язали
нам очі та руки ми не вірили що ми у
Україні ми ще два дні після цього не
вірили що ми не ми ходили Так ми ходимо
до Свободи
просто не усвідомлюєш того що ось все
закінчилося все ж таки буде добре зараз
вже кінець приходить своє русло, але все
і звички залишаються поки що
були в полоні там руки за спиною тримати
їсти на швидкість на це все звичайно
А чий ви одразу милі ще є нова
просто
часу було багато
свого життя Звичайно тому що там крім
як
голодувати і цілодобово нічого не
робити в принципі ти більше нічого не
робиш тільки Як ти думаєш читаєш
книжки дуже багато книг до речі там
прочитала нам давали книги
Донецької бібліотеки ці книги були але ми
бачили просто але займатися чимось треба
було тому читали діти ваші плани дали
виїжджатимуть і доньки Ну зараз ми
пройдемо тут лікування потім ми їдемо на
реабілітацію, а потім вже звичайно до доньки
до мами
[музика]
скучила Ну і з часом я повернуся
назад в Україну, бо Україна це
моя рідна країна Я розумію, що я буду
за нею дуже нудьгувати коли я поїду і що
я надовго не зможу залишитися немає тому
я думаю що я повернуся А я кому місці Ви
хотіла б жити
Мені дуже подобається місто Дніпро Вікторія
душі дякую Вам за розмову за вашу
історію
брежеться б і надати проживання Алісі
велике спасибі